mais d'un
monsieur bonsoir je me suis toujours
demandé parce que quand je suis à votre
place je réponds bonsoir à voix basse je
me suis toujours demandé si tout le
monde dit bonsoir comme moi messieurs
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir our et je
remercie je suis enseignant et avant
d'être enseignant j'ai été élève comme
certainement la plupart d'entre vous
j'ai passé 19 à 20 ans sur les bancs de
l'école
l'école m'a appris des choses que dont
je me sers tous les jours lire écrire
compter
et l'école m'a également appris des
choses dont je ne me suis jamais servi
et dont je ne me servirai certainement
jamais ce que j'ai envie de vous
expliquer ce soir c'est que le rôle de
l'école aujourd'hui doit à mon humble
avis changé elle ne doit plus se
contenter de transmettre des
connaissances comme elle l'a longtemps
fait mais elle doit apprendre aux élèves
à apprendre pour vous expliquer cela je
vais revenir un peu sur le l'histoire de
l'école mais très rapidement il y encore
quelques dizaines d'années on va dire
l'école était vraiment le lieu de la
connaissance l'instituteur était un
personnage très important dans le
village aujourd'hui quand je me promène
dans dunkerque personne ne m'arrête le
lui c'était vraiment le lieu de la
connaissance de l'une des portes
d'entrée après on a fait d'autres la
bibliothèque l'université mais l'école
était le lieu d'entrée de la
connaissance
aujourd'hui on peut dire que les choses
ont changé par rapport à cette
connaissance qui n'est plus uniquement à
l'école à cause grâce
j'ai envie de dire grâce à un réseau
internet qui nous donne une multitude
d'informations
partout où que vous soyez vous pouvez
avoir accès à cette connaissance est
toujours à n'importe quel moment de la
journée et de la nuit là pendant que je
parle si je vous donne des chiffres vous
allez pouvoir le vérifier sur votre
smartphone
alors si le rôle de l'école doit changer
je pense que c'est justement à cause de
cette révolution qu'il ya eu sur la
place de la connaissance
l'école doit pas être justement
apprendre aux enfants non plus ne doit
plus le remplir leur tête comme on
pourrait dire simplement mais leur
apprendre à s'y retrouver dans cette
quantité d'informations les meilleures
écoles du monde ne pourrez pas vous
apprendre aujourd'hui une infime partie
de ce qu'on trouve sur internet
un étudiant par exemple dans une
université prestigieuses comme harvard
lui va avoir une information qui est
trié qui est commentée qui a été
réfléchi en amont
alors est ce que justement l'école ne
doit pas beaucoup plus travaillé sur cet
aspect à prendre et reconnaître une
source par exemple sur internet parce
que figurez vous et ça je pense que je
ne vais pas je vais enfoncer des portes
ouvertes figurez vous que tout ce qui
est marqué sur internet n'est pas
forcément vrai ma question est ce qu'on
n'est pas en train de former des enfants
aujourd'hui ce que j'ai fait pendant
cette semaine à l'école ce que mes
collègues enseignants font est ce qu'on
n'est pas en train de former des enfants
à la version 2.0
ce qui est déjà pas trop mal mais pour
des enfants qui deviendront des adultes
à la version 10.0 donc voila mon
questionnement l'école doit apprendre à
apprendre
pour y arriver il ya plusieurs chemins
jeu jacques sereys je vais vous
l'illustré à travers mon expérience sur
lui avec 2.2 point qu'il semble
important le premier c'est mettre les
enfants en action aujourd'hui sur les
bancs des écoles et je me mets dans le
sac
enfin je mets mes élèves dans le sac on
est trop passif trop consommateur si
vous avez des ados qui reviennent du
collège demandez leur ce qu'ils ont fait
vous aurez vite la répondu je pense je
généralise
heureusement c'est il ya quelques
moments de la classe qui sortent du lot
et donc mettre les enfants en action une
petite formule de benjamin franklin que
j'aime beaucoup
tu me dis j'oublie tu m'as plus de
pardon j'oubliais une fraise tum
enseigne je me souviens tu m'implique
j'apprends je pense que ça parle à
chacun d'entre nous quand on est en
action on applique son corps on retient
mieux
donc la première chose pour que l'école
apprennent à apprendre à nos élèves
c'est de les mettre en action et arrêter
de denfert des consommateurs je m'en
souviendrai lundi devant mes élèves
la deuxième chose leur apprendre et leur
donner le goût à la curiosité c'est
l'une des premières choses que je dis le
jour de la rentrée
c'est un peu particulier en cp ils
pensent tous que ce soir ils vont savoir
lire donc déjà ça c'est la première
chose que je le redis aujourd'hui
désolé vous ne saurez pas dire ce soir
pas tous
donc la première chose que je leur dise
et soyez curieux quand vous êtes curieux
vous vous intéressez au monde qui vous
entoure et les élèves ne le ressentent
souvent pendant l'année à monsieur je
suis curieux tu as changé une affiche de
place ça parle sur des petits détails
mais c'est à mon avis essentiel dans le
dans cette volonté de changer d'école
alors l'institution nous a fait croire
et nous fait toujours croire qu'en
distribuant du matériel à grands coups
de financement c'est souvent du matériel
assez coûteux on va réussir à faire
rentrer ses enfants dans le monde
numérique et donc leur donner cet accès
à la connaissance
voilà le matériel qu'on nous avait
distribué en 1985 j'étais en cm2 c'était
le plan informatique pour tous ceux qui
avaient été décidées par le gouvernement
ce matériel a servi je vais pas non plus
dire que ça n'a pas servi mais il est
très vite devenue obsolète
pour l'anecdote les postes que vous
voyez est équipé de crayon optique
c'était une révolution à l'époque je me
souviens mon enseignant qui m'en parlait
qu'ils savaient pas trop l'utiliser mais
nous on était tous émerveillés
on pouvait intervenir sur l'écran
directement ce crayon optique a fait
long feu étant donné que la souris est
apparu juste après aujourd'hui encore
vous avez peut-être entendu dans
l'actualité il ya deux ou trois semaines
on nous annonce que tous les élèves de
5e vont être équipés de tablettes
merveille miracle vous comprenez bien je
suis un peu arrogant par rapport à ça
mais le problème c'est qu'on considère
dans ses plans numériques que l'outil
est la solution
alors que l'outil n'est qu'un moyen et
qu'il faut qu'on travaille sur les
usages alors très modestement j'aimerais
vous partager ce que j'ai vécu en classe
de cp à dunkerque lé pas très loin d'ici
avec mes élèves voilà cinq ans que
j'expérimente c'est une expérimentation
qui commence à faire des petits aussi
j'expérimente l'utilisation du réseau
social twitter avec mes élèves alors
très rapidement pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas twitter qui en ont juste
entendu parler parce qu'on en parle
quand même un petit peu dans le média
twitter est un réseau social sur lequel
vous pouvez vous inscrire vous avez un
compte à partir de ce compte vous pouvez
produire des messages courts limités à
140 caractères c'est la règle ça vient
du de la longueur des sms à l'époque et
ses messages son public c'est à dire que
c'est quelqu'un ici dans la salle au
premier rang est en train d'écrire un
tweet même quelqu'un qui n'a pas twitter
qui n'est pas inscrit peu ce soir allez
lire le tweet qui a été écrit par une
personne de la salle le les personnes
qui nous lisent des dons qui lisent les
élèves de ma classe qui lisent le compte
de ma classe sont des gens qui ont fait
le choix de me suivre de s'abonner à mon
compte donc la classe à un compte et
pour pouvoir lire mes tweets même si on
peut les lire sans être abonné on peut
si on peut s'y abonner c'est à dire que
quand je vais ouvrir mon compte twitter
je vais avoir les derniers tweets des
personnes que j'ai choisi de suivre
j'espère que je ne vous en brouille pas
alors concrètement je présente twitter à
mes élèves en leur disant on va écouter
mais mes chers élèves vous allez être
les petits journalistes de ma classe on
a quatre murs on ne sait pas trop ce qui
se passe dans la classe quelquefois papa
maman demande le soir alors qu'est ce
que tu as fait j'ai fait un dessin j'ai
été poussé dans la cour enfin toute la
journée n'y passe pas et là les enfants
ont pour tâche de décrire des courts
messages quotidiennement régulièrement à
destination de qui veut bien le lire
donc moi je leur présente 110 ans c'est
le monde entier qui va vous lire
l'enfant comme vous voyez sur cette
illustration à un petit cahier
d'écrivains ça veut dire que je ne suis
pas dans ce du tout numérique c'est
encore dans mon programme d'apprendre à
écrire à la main c'est un peu
d'actualité vous avez aussi certainement
entendu que hier ses sorties dans la
presse la finlande abandonne
l'apprentissage de l'écriture manuscrite
mais ce sera l'objet d'autres débats
donc je passe par l'écriture manuscrite
puis on passe sur du numérique pour
pouvoir envoyer le message sur twitter
sur le compte de la classe donc voilà à
quoi ressemble le compte commun d'une
classe avec les derniers tweets en tête
de en tête de liste en sachant que
l'enfant qui écrit sur twitter un vrai
avantage c'est qu'il sait qu'il est lui
et ça change tout entre écrire pour le
maître écrire pour papa ou maman à la
rigueur papa et maman il ya déjà un
progrès ou écrire pour le monde entier
et pourquoi s'est-il qui les lui parce
que simplement il y a des retours les
gens vont faire des réponses vont poser
des questions vont re tweeté le message
c'est à dire vont l'envoyer à leur
propre réseau pouvant mettre une petite
étoile et ça les enfants sont très cools
temps là cette semaine j'avais encore un
enfant qui attendait sagement devant
l'écran je suis dit mais qu'est ce que
tu attends et dit j'aime bien quand les
gens qui me lisent et donc il attendait
d'avoir des retours du message qui
venait d'envoyer tout simplement
alors vous êtes parent je suis votre ans
chez l'enseignant de votre enfant et
voilà vous savez que j'utilise twitter
et vous venez me voir à la rentrée en
disant écoutez ça suffit non les écrans
y en a c'est ya déjà la télé il y passe
son temps devant les jeux vidéo moi j'ai
envie qu'ils jouent un peu dans le
jardin qui saher qu'ils imaginent qu'ils
créent des choses alors vous vous doutez
bien que j'ai la réponse c'est sûr que
les enfants
je pourrais les mettre devant les écrans
les abandonner en disant voilà twitter
tu peux écrire
qu'est ce qui pourrait se passer il
pourrait tomber sur du contenu qui n'est
pas adapté à l'enfant images ou texte
il pourrait simplement ne pas savoir
écrire ils sont en cb je vous rappel ils
ont 6 ans et donc mon choix non c'est de
les accompagner de leur prendre la main
de dire voilà c'est un nouvel outil
c'est un nouvel outil maintenant ça
commence à dater
c'est un des outils numériques qui
concerne ton quotidien
et voilà ce qu'on peut faire et donc
pour écrire ce genre de tweets
là où c'est un sujet d'une importance
capitale la météo qu'il fait à dunkerque
généralement les parisiens disent non
c'est pas possible il peut pas faire ce
temps donc on a mis la photo à l'appui
bonjour il fait beau c'était le 10
novembre à dunkerque il y a du soleil il
fait très beau signer adrian edwards
ce que vous voyez là ça nécessite au
moins en début d'année
plusieurs heures de travail et je ne
mens pas en disant plusieurs heures de
travail pour un cp la cette époque lot
10 novembre
l'enfant qui le binôme d'enfants qui a
fait ça a au moins passé trente à
quarante minutes entre la conception
partir de l'oral à chercher les sons
pour produire les mots et pour l'envoyer
sur twitter donc voilà ce sont mes
objectifs pédagogiques qui sont derrière
en détournant un outil comme twitter
j'ai l'impression que je perds mais
justement à l'école d'apprendre à
apprendre comme je disais que je permet
aux enfants de s'emparer d'un outil qui
certes aura certainement changer l'année
prochaine mais de s'emparer d'un outil
est de le prendre pour réaliser un
apprentissage en collaboration apprendre
à apprendre c'est aussi savoir s'éduquer
un petit peu à la vie sociale je vous ai
mis une photo de quelque chose que vous
avez peut-être vécu dans votre jeunesse
c'était les fameux parcours dans les
cours de récréation où on faisait du
vélo on apprenait à s'arrêter au feu
rouge
l'ennui section passé au feu rouge il se
passait rien ne c'était pas très grave
donc voilà sans twitter j'aurais pu
apprendre à mes élèves effectivement
dire at internet
il ya des dangers je vous les apprendre
mais on vit pas pour du vrai convient
pas pour du vrai si on n'agit pas
j'aurais pu aussi leur faire peur comme
c'est souvent le cas dans l'éducation
malheureusement ai je vraiment je le
j'en suis bien triste
des interventions qui présente internet
comme le diable disait attention il ya
plein de dangers voilà comment tu peux
tu entend préserver très bien très bien
mais est-ce que justement il faut pas le
vivre pour apprendre à s'en préserver
donc je ne les balances pas entre
guillemets sur des sites qui ne sont pas
pour eux on va sur twitter ces guides et
je suis avec eux et on n'avance pas pop
pour une vraie éducation et pour du vrai
entre guillemets alors très concrètement
en fonction de ce qui arrive
des réponses qui peuvent être faites on
écrit alors vous voyez je sais pas si
c'est très visible de loin mais il ya
une petite affiche
à côté de l'enfant qui est en train
d'envoyer un tweet avec son style et une
petite affiche qui s'appelle le code de
twitter qui est comme le code de la
route ou les enfants ont désigné ont
écrit les règles importantes pour
pouvoir utiliser twitter de façon
sereine
ça peut concerner une première image de
sa vie numérique
pardon une première un premier point de
l'image numérique par exemple apprendre
qu'on choisit un avatar kit images qui
vous correspond baky qui est qui est
bien pour vous que ce qu'on écrit ça
engage non seulement ça vous engage
votre image ne s'engage aussi la classe
donc la politesse le respect de
l'orthographe est donc progressivement
se cote de twitter peut s'améliorer
alors comme je vous disais l'expérience
a fait des petits j'ai eu l'opportunité
d'avoir plusieurs médias qui sont venus
dans la classe voir ce qui se passait
j'ai pu aller présenter le projet auprès
du ministère et il ya eu des suites
étant donné que maintenant le l'accès
aux réseaux sociaux est écrit noir sur
blanc dans nos programmes informatiques
informatiques ont pas dire numérique
parce que là je parle alors comme une
ancienne école
et puis j'ai eu l'opportunité et la
chance d'aller rencontrer les
enseignants innovants dans plusieurs
forums dans le monde entier ce qui m'a
valu aussi de me dire oui ce qu'on
change de façon très anodine dans nos
classes ça peut ça peut faire changer le
monde
on est vraiment dans l'esprit tedx les
idées peuvent changer le monde a gelé
vécu ce que j'ai appris à mes élèves
hier je pense que demain ce sera presque
périmés par exemple le twitter que je
leur apprend à utiliser cette année
l'année prochaine ce sera plus le même
et d'ailleurs celui d'il ya cinq ans
quand j'ai commencé c'était pas du tout
la même façon de fonctionner ce que je
veux dire par là c'est que si dans mon
action de classe et dans ce qu'on peut
proposer nous en tant qu'éducateur ou en
tant que parent en famille on arrive à
l'heure donné l'envi d'utiliser des
outils qui sont nouveaux s'en emparer
pour leur donner une curiosité les
mettre en action comme je disais au
début
je pense que l'on pourra faire de nos
enfants les bonzes adultes de demain je
vous remercie